ليس من غير المعتاد أن
يجد فريق التشجيع نفسه يسقط، لكن
المشجع أوستن بيم صُدم عندما
وجد سرواله يسقط
أمام حشد من سبعين ألفًا
في مباراة كرة قدم في آيوا هوكيز. ما
كان أول تلميح لك بأن شيئًا ما كان
خاطئًا، يمكن أن أشعر به  مثل
الريح الطفيفة بين ساقي وبالتأكيد
عندما هبطت كان سروالي هو كاحلي،
لذلك قام بسحبهما للأعلى حتى أثناء
استخدام الدواسة للخلف بشراسة، وأشار أحد المعلقين
إلى أنني تعثرت بمجرد ارتداء سروالي بشكل
طبيعي، ومع ذلك يمكن لهذا الرجل أن يفعل ذلك بعد ذلك
كان أوستن
يمارس رياضة الجمباز منذ أن كان في التاسعة من عمره،
يقول في البداية إنه كان محرجًا بشأن
سرواله ولكن بعد ذلك كان لديه شعور
ربما لم يره أحد، نعم لقد
انتشر على الجانب المشرق، اختار
يومًا جيدًا للشمال للذهاب إلى الكوماندوز  وكان من الممكن أن
يكون الأمر أسوأ بكثير عندما
تعثرت هذه المرأة في رباط الحذاء أثناء وجودها على
جهاز المشي وانتهى بها الأمر وهي
ترتدي ملابسها، تجاهلت
الحادث بهذه الكلمات الخالدة،
كل شخص لديه مؤخرة، على الأقل
تمت تغطية مؤخرة أوستن بسراويل ضغط Nike Pro،
هل أنت كذلك؟  اتخاذ أي نوع من
التدابير الوقائية للتأكد من أن هذا
لن يحدث مرة أخرى، أنا فقط أربط
سروالي بإحكام شديد، سجلت أم أوستن الفخورة
ابنها
[تصفيق]
بينما كان يتقلب وشعر بأن سرواله
ينزلق في منطقة النهاية ويكشف
نهايته  منطقة للعالم جينيموس سي إن إن نيويورك